Gags, Gags, Gags, schön, dass ihr da seid. Gags, hier ist Titzel Titzel,itzel. Hä? Und jetzt nur noch. Also ich glaube, dass der Dritte Weltkrieg natürlich mit anderen Waffen geführt werden wird. Wir haben uns verändert, Stefan. Wollen wir mal so einen kleinen Rückschau machen? Das Jahr neigt sich dem Ende zu. Wollen wir noch mal komplett zurückgucken, wie haben wir uns entwickelt, was ist passiert? Sind wir vielleicht irgendwo falsch abgebogen? Ich glaube, ich bin ein paar Mal falsch abgebogen. Schreibt mal bitte die Folge in die Kommentare, in der wir falsch abgebogen sind, wo alles in falsche Richtung genommen hat. Schickt uns mal die Stellen, rausgekoppelt als mp3 oder 4 Datei, je nachdem, ob man noch irgendwie so verfixt das Podcast-UFO Punkt-Pufo Logo findet. Und das zeigt uns, wo sind wir falsch abgebogen. Wäre das was? Ist das eigentlich, wir haben ja schon alles erreicht als Podcast-Ufo. Wir haben,
unsere Praktikantin hat einen Podcast-Preis gewonnen,
wir haben einen eigenen Emoji
in den Äther gestossen. Den hat sie uns
nicht gegeben, ist das richtig? Ne, den hat sie uns nie
zurückgegeben. Und sie antwortet auch nicht auf unsere
Mails, also die ist verschwunden. Die hat sich mit dem
deutschen Podcast-Preis
2019 in die Karibik abgesetzt,
richtig? Ja, was, sag ich mal, langfristig jetzt auch ein mittelmässig guter Plan ist, wenn die sitzt jetzt irgendwo in Argentinien mit ihrem Podcastpreis und dachte sich, okay, was war der nächste Schritt von meinem Plan, aber viel Erfolg, Thais. Und eine gute Bireliste und die ist dann tatsächlich leer. Also eine Einkaufsliste. Cerveza, leche. Cerveza, leche? Was heißt Einkaufsliste auf Spanisch? No sé. Und das einzige, was jetzt eigentlich noch kommen kann, ist die .pufo-Dateiendung. Wie gut wäre das denn? Eine Pufo-Dateiendung. Wir haben eine eigene Dateiendung. Und es ist so eine, ich würde sagen, es ist so eine A3D-Bild. Es ist so ein Shield-Bild. Oh, ich war erst mal kaputt. Es ist eine fehlerhafte Datei, die wird automatisch in Punkt Pupo umgenommen. Genau, so wie bei Punkt Sip muss man dann erst doppelklicken und es reparieren. Das finde ich immer das Beste, wenn das Programm mich fragt, soll ich die Datei reparieren? Und dann denke ich so, ja, mach mal. Ja, vor allem, man könnte auch so sarkastisch auf, nee, ich wollte jetzt eine kaputte Datei öffnen, klicken. Kann man aber nicht. Aber ich denke,, manchmal so ein Sarkasmus-Mode wäre geil, so ein Okay, auch wenn oben steht, Sie haben seit 3700 Tagen kein Update durchgeführt, wollen Sie es durchführen oder nee, ich kann auch noch einen Tag länger warten. So ein lustiger Knopf. Nee, jetzt ist es auch schon scheißegal. Jetzt ist es eh schon egal, jetzt ist mir eh alles scheißegal. Oder halt Update machen und no risk no fun, so der andere Knopf. Einfach mal auch ein bisschen Würze mit reinbringen. Oder auf so einen Knopf, so einen entschuldigen, ach scheiße, nee sorry, Knopf. So einer, der so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, ein bisschen mehr Emotion. Ich glaube, deswegen stumpfen wir auch ab, weil wir immer vom Computer hängen und man kann nur auf ja, nein, okay, auf gefällt mir, gefällt mir nicht. Es gibt seltenen Button,
generell ja, gute Idee, ist es gerade zeitlich
nur ein bisschen schwierig. Es passt nicht, weil ich keine
in dieses Meeting muss. So ein riesiger
Blocktext einfach.
Da klickt man drauf.
Stimmt schon, ich bin auch kein Fan von
Fenstern, die nur eine Antwortmöglichkeit haben,
vor allem es gibt manchmal so, bei Twitch gibt es das,
dass du so eine Nachricht kriegst und der einzige
Button ist Danke. Und ich sag, Moment mal, nee. Und dann kriegst du sie mal das, dass du so eine Nachricht kriegst und der einzige Button ist Danke.
Und ich sage, Moment mal, nee. Und dann kriegst du sie mal weg, machst du mit Command-Q. Ja, Command-Q, ich mache einfach schön lange, lange auf die Escape-Taste drücken, bis der Computer aus ist. Deine Rebellion ist das. Ja, kein Danke. Ich muss immer noch darüber lachen. Und das zeigt auch, ich bin nicht verstumpft. Und ich habe immer noch Lust und Elan. Ja, wisshaftig, wenn man die Maus bei Apple, Macbooks zum Beispiel, schnell bewegt, wird sie gross, die Maus. Ja, das ist das Beste. Und immer wenn ich schlecht drauf bin, bewege ich so ruckartig, rubbelnartig das Mauspad und dann wird der Pfeil so ganz gross und dann muss ich immer lachen. Ja, das ist immer lustig, damit man weiß, wo er ist, weil manchmal verliert man ja seinen Kurs. Oder ist er ja? Oder ist er doch? Hier bin ich, hallo, hier bin ich, was willst du? Das ist einfach grossartig. Einfach so auch immer so wackeln, das hat so was ganz, wie so ein Tier einfach, dass man so schüttelt und dann faucht es einmal auf wie eine Katze, der drückt man irgendwie auf die Tatze, dann faucht sie dich an und man sagt, ja es lebt. Ja, lebt. Es reicht auch schon. Es lebt, es ist da, es ist healthy and alive. Ich bin ja, sage ich mal, mittlerweile total riskant unterwegs, denn ich habe für mich entdeckt, Badewanne plus Elektrotechnik ist mein neues Bandit-Jumping. Der nächste Lebensport. Du hast eine GoPro auf und dann wird das mal schön der Föhn in die Wanne genommen. Ja, tatsächlich, ich habe auch gemerkt, dass die Kopf-Gopro, was die Erotik angeht, in Ordnung ist für eine Badewannensituation, weil du weißt, die Person ist nackt, du siehst aber nur den Kopf, was so eine gewisse erotische Spannung erzeugt. Wie sieht es denn runter aus? Wie angezogen sein? Naja, nee, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, man ist schon anders, wenn man, es ist ja oft so, ich habe oft so Zoom-Meetings, wo ich splitternackt bin, aber halt, man sieht nur den Oberkörper, aber es ist schon eine andere Stimmung einfach. Hörst du gerne nackt rum in der Wohnung? Tatsächlich schon ab und zu, ja.
Ich habe tatsächlich gegenüber...
Aber dann komplett nackt, oder reden wir von einer Unterhose?
Nee, nee, wir reden von einer kurzen Hose, also Unterhose nie.
Ohne Unterhose?
Ohne Unterhose, aber Hose.
Das ist Maximum, das ist Maximum, mehr nicht.
Wir reden nie von später Fasernackt.
Ich habe tatsächlich das Erste, was ich gemacht habe in meiner Wohnung, ich habe mich auf Gliedhöhe begeben mit meinem Kopf, also mein eigenes. Ja, also ich bin in die Hocke, Splittertack bin ich in die Hocke gegangen und habe geguckt, was kann ich von der Höhe aus sehen, rückschlüssig, wer kann auf die Höhe sehen. Und was dann mit so Lasern, die dann montiert, das aufwendig, genau markiert, wo kann ich lang gehen, nackt. Genau, weil oft ist es ja so, du bist nackt und siehst eine Person im anderen Haus und man sieht sich ja gegenseitig nicht, aber man ist trotzdem gegenseitig nackt und das hat natürlich auch eine prickelnde Spannung. Aber ich bin in der Badewanne mit meinem Bügelbrett und Laptop und dann ist es auch so, ein kleiner Bügelbrett auf der Bügelbrett. Ja, ein kleines Bügelbrett, das übertreibt man nicht. Sorry, kleines, so ein riesiges Bügelbrett auf der bügelbrett, ein kleines Bügelbrett das übertreibt man nicht kleines, so ein riesiges Bügelbrett ein Junggesellenbügelbrett der ab und zu seine Socken bügelt aber mehr auch nicht, ein gut verstaubares Junggeselle oder Kind, der einfach sehr kleine Kleidung hat und dann einfach genug zu bügeln, schön quer auf die Badewanne gelegt und obendrauf dann Laptop. Das genau heißt quer. 90 Grad zur
Badewanne-Richtung, zur Liegerichtung.
Schöne Definition.
Und genau, liegt dann quer
drauf. Und da, kleiner Tipp,
auch an die Technikfreaks da draußen,
kleiner Shoutout, nasse Hände
und Touchpad funktioniert nicht
lange. Also die
Laptop-Touchpads sind ja eh noch mal anders
als diese
Glasscheiben, aber da ist es auch immer so, man steigt in die Badewanne, ist voller Energie und klickt sich irgendwie durch, durchs Internet irgendwie surft, während man in der Badewanne liegt. Aber je nasser die Hand wird, desto mehr Tropfen darauf kommen, desto weirder wird die Maus, die dann ab und zu hin und her springt oder immer Rechtsklick gedrückt hat oder plötzlich so zittert die ganze Zeit. Man denkt sich, aber es geht noch. Ich komme durch. Das ist schon so, wenn man, um jetzt die Bungee-Jumping-Metapher aufzumachen, ist wie man zieht an der Schnur, aber der Fallschirm öffnet sich nicht. Man hat aber noch ein paar Meter. Das ist so ein bisschen das Äquivalent zu, das Touchpad wird zu nass. Wie viel hält der auch aus, der Laptop, bis er sagt, nee, das war's? Weiß ich nicht. Das ist wie immer Bun Jumping, du gehst auf die Treppe und der Instructor kichert. Und dann denkst du dir, schlechtes Zeichen. I don't know what this. Und so ist es auch, wenn bei mir der Cursor anfängt zu zittern und zu wackeln und dann dreht er sich so um, dann ist er falsch rum. Und dann geht er so über den Bildschirm hinaus. Die Eierohrzimmer. Ganz merkwürdig auf jeden Fall.
Und ich
versuche dann aber noch so eine ganz erbärmliche
halbe Stunde weiter
zu surfen, obwohl der Cursor mir ganz
deutlich macht, nein, das
funktioniert so nicht. Ich leide,
ich habe Schmerzen, bis ich irgendwann sage,
weißt du was, lassen wir es und dann
tauche ich unter und dann
nimmst du den Laptop mit dir in den Tod. Ich weiß nicht genau, ich denke mir erst mal, wenn ich auf die Idee komme, einen Laptop mit in die Badewanne zu nehmen, da eine Serie zu gucken oder einen Film zu gucken oder einen Podcast zu hören, denke ich mir immer, warum machst du das nicht häufiger? Mega geil, freue ich mich jetzt mega drauf, dann sitzt man in der Badewanne, hat wieder das Handtuch vergessen, was man sich daneben hinlegen sollte, um die Hände immer abzutrocknen, fasst das Touchpad an mit den nassen Händen und denkt sich, ah, ja, deswegen. Das ist der Grund, warum man das nicht häufiger macht, weil das Wasser ein scheisselement dafür ist. Immer noch das beste, eines der besten Elemente, also ich würde sagen, nach Erde und Luft, das beste Element, was mit Laptop klarkommt, aber es ist nicht oben, es ist nicht oben dabei. Top drei von vier ist nicht gut, muss man auch ganz ehrlich sagen. Also ganz ehrlich? Wirklich nicht gut. Nicht geil. Aber ich finde es auch gut, dass wir den ganzen Tag Serien schauen und zur Entspannung schauen wir eine Serie in der Wadwander. Wadwander. Jetzt erstmal ein bisschen Entspannung, muss auch sein. Ich finde das mittlerweile Netflix fast wie so ein Fernseher, wie ein Fernsehprogramm, macht irgendwas an. Du bist verrückt. Aber wie, aber erlaube ich sehr viele Menschen. Es läuft dann einfach nebenbei, oder? Es läuft dann einfach nebenbei. Ich mache irgendwas an, es gibt halt Serien, die ich bewusst gucke, und ich habe aber auch auf meiner Watchlist so ein paar Nebenbei-Serien, wie so man, wenn man so durchscrollt, dann landet man bei Dreisat, läuft gerade irgendwie ein alter Film auf Schwarz-Weiss und man denkt, das klingt jetzt ganz schön im Hintergrund meiner Wohnung, läuft das jetzt einfach so ein bisschen rum, während man kocht, während man was anderes macht. Läuft einfach Netflix nebenbei, ich hab so ein paar Nebenbeiserien. Hast du das auch? Nee, hab ich nicht tatsächlich. Ich bin immer First Screen, Full Focus First Screen, bin ich immer dabei und macht eine Serie an, lasst sie zehn Minuten laufen und weil ich hab mir wirklich den Second Screen abgewöhnt, ich hab da keinen Bock mehr drauf, irgendwie den Hin und Her zu taben, Handy in der Hand, sondern immer nur First Screen. Und dann, wenn ich merke, es funktioniert nicht, dann sage ich auch, dann geht es halt nicht. Ich finde, man muss sich da nicht noch irgendwie Hoffnung machen und dann nebenbei was machen oder nebenbei. Ich gucke die Serie nur so nebenbei. Dann guckst du der Serie in die Augen und sagst ihr, nee, das mit uns beiden wird nicht funktionieren. Genau. Das war eine kurzfristige Sache. Ja. Ich hatte auch Spaß. Es ist ja wirklich, du musst eine Bindung auch aufgeben können, um zu sagen, nee, dann ist es halt mit uns nichts. Und das ist gesund. Das liegt nicht unbedingt an dir. Du bist eine gut gemachte, gut gebaute Serie. Ja, eine der wenigen guten deutschen Serien, toller Autor, macht auch einen Podcast, aber es reicht halt nicht für mich. Die Gags, nicht jeder zündet irgendwie, die Jugendsprache teilweise cringy und deswegen ist es halt für mich
dann muss ich da auch
aufhören an der Stelle.
Ich finde den Satz
die Jugendsprache fand ich teilweise
echt mega cringy
ist ein guter Satz.
Ultra cringe
Alarm, cringe alert. Da muss man dir in die Augen gucken
und sagen, obwohl du eine gute Serie bist und es nicht an dir liegt, es liegt an mir, an meiner Aufmerksamkeit Spanne, wird es mit uns beiden nicht funktionieren. Und ich habe mich deswegen umgeguckt nach einer neuen. Du, es ist ein tragischer Moment, kommt oft vor. Ich lese einen Artikel, denke mir, ah krass, irgendwie Bhutan, da ist irgendwie eine Militärdiktatur, aha, okay, lese ich mal, nach drei Sätzen denke ich mir, du pass auf, das hat alles sehr schön angefangen mit uns. Und ich dachte, ich bin ein besserer Mensch, du wolltest mich zu einem besseren Menschen machen. Du hast mir auch schöne Augen gemacht mit Wörtern wie Buthan. Ja, Buthan, Militärdiktatur. Und du hast dich, glaube ich, in den Menschen verliebt, der ich nicht bin. Und das ist mir jetzt klar geworden. Du hast jemanden besseren verdient als ich, du hast einen aufmerksamen Leser verdient, jemanden, der die Worte auch versteht und nicht nur den Klang mag und das bin ich nicht. Und ich glaube, ich kann uns viel Schmerz ersparen, wenn ich einfach je nach drei Zeilen sage, Stopp! Halt dein dummes Maul! Lass mich bitte in Ruhe! Halt deine dumme Drecksfresse! Das war's mit uns. Apfelwe. Apfelwe? Ja, Tab schliessen. Du bist aber jemand, der Taps generell eher beibehält. Du hast Tabs offen. Ja, Tabs offen, richtig viele Tabs offen. Natürlich schamvolle Tabs und immer so Sachen, die schau ich später an. Es sind ja auch Sachen im Internet, so vier Stunden lange Videos und so,
irgendeine Konferenz und dann guckst du dann 20 Minuten, den Rest schaue ich später.
Wird nie passieren.
Aber deswegen versuche ich es mir auch aktiv anzutrainieren, häufiger Nein sagen zu können,
um dann auch bei solchen Sachen Nein sagen zu können.
Also ich will richtig gut darin werden, Dinge zu beenden und richtig gut sagen zu können,
Stopp, jetzt reicht es auch mal, ich brauche Platz, ich brauche mehr Freiheit. Es ist wie aufräumen, du musst einfach mal auch mal Tab schliessen, Dinge wegwerfen können, die wirst du nicht mehr benutzen, du wirst den Sandwich Maker nicht mehr benutzen, den kannst du verschenken, verschenken dir bei ebay Kleinanzeigen zum Beispiel. Ja. Du musst mal, das ist das Gleiche, das sind nämlich auch Leute, die nichts wegwerfen können, sind auch die, die Tabs nicht schliessen. Ich kann mittlerweile sehr gut Dinge wegwerfen, Dinge verschenken, Dinge verkaufen und Tabs verkaufen.
Offene Tabs verkaufe ich.
Tabs verschenken finde ich auch gut, weil du hast ja schon eine emotionale Bindung und dann einfach Tab kopieren und einem guten Freund schicken.
Oh mein Gott, mega.
Und dann kann man ihn bei ihm löschen.
Der kann die auch löschen, wenn er will.
Also wenn ihm nicht gefallen, kann er die löschen, der Kumpel.
Ja, oder mal austauschen, gegenseitig mal den Browser und dann einfach mal sagen, jemand anders mistet für dich aus. Gibt es das eigentlich so eine Sendung, es gibt ja dieses, wie heißt die mit, da sitzt Spark Joy und irgendwie so Queer Eye oder so, ich räume dein Leben auf Sendungen. Ich räume dein Laptop auf. Genau, gibt es sowas auch für PC, weil die meisten Menschen verbringen ja mehr Zeit im digitalen Zuderspace.
Wie ist doch mal die Minimalism-Frau bei Netflix?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Die, mit dem asiatischen Namen. Die für Laptops brauche ich gern. Die, wenn mein Laptop ist, sortiert. Das brauche ich nicht, das brauchst du alles nicht. Aber das ist eher ein Sketch, oder? Das ist drei VPNs. Ich räume bei euch so eine Überraschung aus, so Überraschung, wir räumen ein Laptop auf und die Person erst mal kreidebleich. Ja, klar. Und dann wird erst mal geguckt, brauchst du das noch? Hausaufgabenordner, 6,8 Gigabyte, brauchst du das noch? Gehst doch gar nicht mehr zur Schule. Ja, nee, das kann weg. Kann weg. Kann gelöscht werden. Wurde wir noch ein Backup machen oder nicht. Und dann hier 600 Dateien im Ordner Memes, kann das weg? Geh mal kurz bei Safari rein und ich sag dir jetzt ein Random-Datum und eine Random-Uhrzeit, was auch immer, dein Hauptbrowser und ich sag dir ein Random-Datum, Random-Uhrzeit und du sagst mir auf der Seite du warst. Wie geht das denn? Kannst du hier bei mir machen, Verlauf. Zum Beispiel hier, 5. Dezember, ne, geht nicht.
Oh, ich war am Samstag, am 5. Dezember war ich auf nicht vielen Seiten und die meisten davon waren Kugelfisch spezifisch. Ich erinnere mich, was war an dem Tag los? Ich war in der ... Ich war ... ja, wie hole ich aus? Ich hätte gerne eine schöne, große Pflanze für meine Wohnung, bin deswegen in einen, sehr früh aufgestanden, weil es den einen Markt gibt in Köln, wo es richtig schöne, große Pflanzen gibt für die Wohnung, richtig coole, auch so Pflanzen, die man nicht häufig sieht, die sehr cool sind, aber trotzdem auch im Eimpflege leicht und funktionieren. Und dieser Laden ist ein Pflanzen-Grossmarkt und der hat jeden Tag auf zwar, aber nur von fünf bis zehn Uhr morgen. What? Weil es ein Grossmarkt ist. Und ich komme nie dazu, da hinzufahren. Also habe ich mir echt mal für Samstagmorgen zum Wecker gestellt, um hinzufahren, neun Uhr da gewesen. Und der war total scheiße. Der hatte kaum Pflanzen, die mich interessiert haben. Und dann war aber nebenan so ein riesengroßer Megazoolad, der hieß so einfach Megazoo, so ein Tierhandlung. Und dann hatte ich mir, damit sich dieser Samstagmorgen nicht komplett verschenkt anfühlt, gehe ich einfach in diesen Zomarkt und wurde nicht enttäuscht, weil ich habe einen Kugelfisch gesehen. Gesehen, aber nur. Ja, was soll ich sonst mitmachen? Nicht gekauft, nein. Nein, okay. Nee, da bin ich, glaube ich, richtig abgebogen. Ja. Von dieser Phase bin ich weg. Ich kann mittlerweile Megazooläden und die Betonlicht auf Mega betreten, ohne danach ein Tier, sie am besten Kampffampffisch zu kaufen. Aber es gibt so viele
Pflanzenliebhaber, dass jeden Tag
so früh morgens die besten Pflanzen
schon weggekauft werden. Die haben dann eine Ananaspflanze,
einen Ananasbaum und der ist
dann sofort weg jeden Tag. Ich glaube schon, ja.
Die kämpfen dann davor, tagelang
den einen Kirschbaum zu bekommen.
Verleihen Pflanzen auf jeden Fall auch so an
Drehteams und so weiter. Daher kam ich auch auf die,
weil wir auch bei den Pflanzen geliehen haben für so Sets und verkaufen die auch an dann Floristen und so weiter.
Man kann aber auch direkt hin und direkt da kaufen, aber hat keine gute Auswahl mehr. Mag an der Jahreszeit liegen, Dezember ist vielleicht nicht die beste Jahreszeit, um Pflanzen zu kaufen, bin mir nicht sicher. Vielleicht doch in der Innenpflanze, dachte ich. Also eine Riesenenttäuschung, ein Griff ins ...
Ein Cllosett.
Ja, wie, ja, gut.
Kann man schon sagen.
Ich wollte jetzt in der Pflanzmetapher bleiben.
Ach so.
Griff in eine Kaktee.
Ja.
Griff in so eine Distel.
Griff in diese Ultrigaria-Grube, da wo man nicht rauskommt.
Wie ein Griff in eine Ultrigaria letztlich.
Ja, ich glaube, die heißen oft auch eins zu eins genau so.
Kann gut sein, ja.
Und dann bin ich in diesen Megazoo gegangen.
Sehr toll.
Die hatten viel Auswahl. Ja. Eidechsen. Aber das reizt dich gar nicht, da irgendwie mal so ein paar, so zehn Futtermäuse einfach zum Wecksnacken irgendwie mitnehmen und so. Vor allem gibt es ja dieses Lebendfutter, das ist ja ganz spannend. Das ist ja ein Regal, was schreit. Es sind ja einfach Heimchen, Heuschrecken, Fliegen, Würmer, Mehlwürmer. Die schreien jetzt nicht, aber die fliegenden Insekten. Aber gibt es denn eine Solidarität unter Futtertieren oder können die sich auch nicht leiden? Ich habe, die sind sich alle einig, dass es Futtertiere sind. Also die sind sich alle einig, dass sie jetzt keine großen Rechte beanspruchen können, in diesen coolen Gehegen zu sein. Also es ist schon klasse, wie der Mensch einfach so einteilt in Schubladen. Fressen und gefressen werden. Ja, tatsächlich. Der Mensch ist ja einfach für den Bau, da gibt es Riesenabteilungen für Aquaristik, weil Fische ja schön sind teilweise, nicht alle, entscheidet man ja auch ganz doll. Und dann gibt es diese Riesenabteilung, wo man dann so deren Häuser baut und schmückt und tausend Wurzeln. Da gibt es gängigeweise diese Wurzeln, wo man sich auswählen kann und dann dekoriert man das und pflanzt schöne Pflänzchen rein und so weiter, wo man die Häuser schön macht. Und dann gibt es ja diese Eierkartons mit schreienden Tieren, die gekauft werden, um die anderen Tiere zu füttern. Ja, es ist extrem arrogant. Allein die Tatsache, dass ein Vogelhäuschen so aussieht wie ein menschliches Haus. Wie fucking arrogant ist das denn? Einfach zu sagen, das einzige Tier, was er ein Haus baut. Ja, was er näher bauen kann, ja. Oder auch ein Hundehaus. Einfach zu sagen, nee, weißt du was, wir bauen, willst du in einem Kleinhaus von uns wohnen?
Oh nee, ich habe eigentlich ganz andere Bedürfnisse
als ihr. Nein, du nimmst schon mal unser Haus.
Einfach genau so. Und vor allem
nicht mal unser Haus, weil Häuser
sehen ja mittlerweile nicht mehr so Klischee
Hundehaus-mäßig aus, sondern
haben ja dann auf dem Flachter. Wie ein Hauseicon.
So sieht ein Haus aus. Wie ein Klischee,
wie ein Simpsons-Haus. Guck mal, ein kleiner Schornstein. Ja, ich habe keinen Ofen. Ja, bitte, da zieht es schön rein. Also fucking arrogant. Ich hätte gerne zumindest einen Flachdach, weil das macht gar keinen Sinn, dieses Giebel-Zeugs. Warum? Wie muss das sein, für einen Vogel in so einem Vogelhäuschen zu leben? Ist es so komplett falsch? Guckt da mal jemand aus dem Fenster raus oder nicht? Schaukelst du auch auf der Schaukel oder haben wir die umsonst? Geil wäre ein Vogelhaus, wo Fenster drin sind, auf denen kleine schwarze Vögel geklebt sind. Oder kleine Menschen. Ja, kleine Menschen, wenn die regelmässigen Menschen sterben, weil sie gegen die Scheiben von Vogelhäuschen fliegen.
Es wurde jetzt bei Kickstarter, hat ein Kollege von mir gefunden, weil er noch Weihnachtsgeschenke sucht. Ist ja auch eine Zeit jetzt, wo man viele neue Dinge kennenlernt, weil alle so im Internet die meiste Zeit nicht arbeiten, sondern im Internet abhängen, um Geschenke zu suchen und dann auf random stuff kommen. Und der hat gefunden, ein Vogelhäuschen, was immer, wenn ein Vogel darauf landet, so ein Futterhäuschen ist das, also diese Futtermaschine, wenn ein Vogel da landet, wird ein Foto von dem Vogel gemacht und dann kriegt man immer eine Push-Mitteilung auf sein Handy mit einem Bild von diesem sich erschreckenden, nachfotografierten Vogel mit Name des Vogels. Ich finde das eine brillante Idee. Idee. Ach so, das ist ja geil. Also Rotkehlchen. Ihr checkt sofort, welche Art von Vogel das ist. Es ist dann so ein Rotkehlchen mit so einem Doppelkinn, wo du auch nicht weißt, dass es fotografiert wird. Und dann steht ganz Rotkehlchen. Ja, schiebt sich gerade viel zu viel Futter in den Schnabel rein. Wird fotografiert und du kriegst dann direkt ein Pushmetall mit dem Bild. Das finde ich ganz toll, die Idee. Und es ist eignet sich nicht, Kickstarter reignet sich generell nicht für Weihnachtsgeschenke, weil es wird erst in acht Monaten geliefert, wahrscheinlich oder sowas. Aber die hat jetzt schon irgendwie so 20 Millionen eingenommen, weil alle diese Idee brillant finden. Ich finde das auch ganz toll. Ich finde es eine geile Idee, aber ich finde es so gut, wie konsequent das Konzept, man bezahlt mit seinen Daten, wie bei Facebook, Social Media, jetzt auch auf die Tierwelt übertragen wird. Du kriegst was zu fressen, aber dafür machen wir ein Foto von dir und ich will deinen Namen. Einfach so, ich will deine Daten, dafür kriegst du was zu essen. Aber wo du gerade richtig angesagt hast, viele bleiben drin, viele bleiben zu Hause und es entwickelt sich auch ein neuer Lebensstil. Und da will ich eine kleine Empfehlung aussprechen, nämlich der neue Podcast von unserer guten ehemaligen Kollegin Julia Becker, Drinnis heißt er. Julia Becker und Chris Sommer machen zusammen Podcasts. Wir freuen Chris Sommer, ganz toll. Über alles, was zu tun hat mit dem Thema introvertiert sein. Die haben immer so Tipps, was man gut machen kann, wenn man introvertiert ist und was man gut zu Hause machen kann. Super Podcast, Drinnis, hört auf jeden Fall rein. Und ich glaube, es ist strategisch sehr klug, jetzt Produkte für Introvertierte zu machen, weil ich glaube, es kommen viele Leute gerade auf den Geschmack. Schön, dass du da direkt so eine Haifisch-Attitüde allestierst. Nee, es ist ein wachsender Markt, weil ich glaube, viele sind jetzt auch auf den Geschmack gekommen, so wir müssen drinbleiben. Ja, es hat gar keiner mehr Bock, drin zu sein. Also eins von beiden. Ich glaube, es kommen mehr auf den Geschmack. Ich glaube auch. Ich glaube, aber vor allem, stell dir mal vor, es gäbe jetzt so den Anti-Lockdown. So nicht,
du musst den ganzen Tag zu Hause bleiben, sondern du darfst
nur noch zum Schlafen zu Hause
sein. Finde ich das Schlimmste. Wie furchtbar schrecklich
wäre das denn? Aber da werden bestimmt auch Leute
ein paar von sich entdecken, dass sie extrovertiert
sind, wenn sie dann ständig auf Partys sein
müssen. Sie denken, wow. Und ich glaube, so ist es genau auch.
Viele Leute entdecken, ach, es gibt auch ein anderes Leben.
Die andere Seite ist viel besser.
Tolle Idee und liebe Julia, wollte ja nie einen Podcast machen, hat sie ja damals noch bei uns erzählt, als ich zu Gast war, hat sich immer Angst vorgehabt. Ich finde es toll, dass sie es hingekriegt hat, weil Julia ist ein unglaublich lustiger Mensch. Ja, super. Ich lache mich kaputt, auch ihr Buch ist ganz toll, das Leben ist eines der härtesten. Ich lache mich jedes Mal kaputt, wenn ich mit ihr spreche, von daher hört in den Podcast rein. Ja, großartig. ganz toll, und ich möchte dann auch nochmal, wo wir gerade in so einer Empfehlungsecke sind, unsere eigene Community ans Herz legen, nämlich unsere Podcast-UFO-Telegram-Gruppe, weil die, das wollte ich letzte Woche eigentlich schon erzählen, die haben nämlich, und da ist ganz toll, was da passiert, denn das ist wirklich eine ganz tolle kleine Gruppe, die nicht mehr so klein
ist, mittlerweile hat es sehr viele Mitglieder,
aber da passiert so viel cooles
Zeug, was wir ja gar nicht mehr mitbekommen
und wir auch keinen Einfluss haben, was ich auch ganz cool finde,
dass wir da
jetzt nicht entscheiden müssen oder sowas, weil da passiert
ganz autark, ganz tolles Zeug.
Ich habe mittlerweile das Gefühl, dass wir da eher
ungern gesehen sind in der Telegrammgruppe.
Ich komme da mal rein, schreibe manchmal, hey, neue Folge ist da und dann ist still und ich denke mir so, okay, ich gehe ja schon wieder und dann reden die wieder weiter über ihr Zeug. Manchmal reden die auch, ja, und manchmal reden die noch in deiner Gegenwart dann über dieses weirde Zeug, was da vorher. Und das ist viel spannender als dann wir, was ich aber auch toll und sympathisch finde. Das ist so wie Kinder, auf die man irgendwann nicht mehr aufpassen muss, wo man einfach sagen kann, macht mal euer Ding und die machen dann coole Projekte, wie zum Beispiel den Podcast-Sufow Adventskalender. Da könnt ihr draufgehen, schaut mal in die Telegram-Gruppe, das ist die erste Nachricht, das ist angepinnt und ihr könnt mitmachen beim Podcast-Ufow Adventskalender, ihr könnt dann auf die Tage klicken und da hat dann jeder aus der Community etwas beigesteuert, was ganz toll ist, sei es ein Weihnachtsgedicht, ganz viele Songs, ein Song. Wie kommt man auf die Telegram-Gruppe? Einfach auf telegram.de slash nein, weiß ich nicht. Man findet die einfach bei das Podcast so. Ja, sucht die einfach bei Telegram. Telegram-Gruppe mittlerweile so erfolgreich, dass ich die App Telegram nicht mehr benutzen kann, weil ich da drin bin und so viele Notifications kriege, dass ich die App nicht mehr benutze. Also das ist auch schon manchmal ein gutes Zeichen. Das ist auch ein gutes Zeichen. Für den Erfolg dieses
Projekts. Nein, kann man alles stummschalten, aber
ja, da sind ja jetzt auch eh alle
wegen Michael Wendler und Attila Hildmann
und so. Haben jetzt ja eh alle Podcasts.
Ich glaube, ist eh irgendwie die App geworden.
Es ist schon eine weirde Gegend geworden. Wo sollen wir umziehen?
Oder helfen wir gerade aktiv?
Ist aber die Frage, lässt man sich sowas wegnehmen?
Als Leute, die auf der richtigen Seite stehen?
Die alte Peppa the Frog?
Die alte, die uralte, ewig dagewesene, tausend Jahre alte Pepe the Frog-Diskussion. Ja. Nee, aber lustigerweise, dass Slavoj Zizek sagt ja wohl, das ist ja großer Rammstein-Fan. Ja. Also, weiß ich nicht. Aber weil er ja sagt, dass Rammstein es richtig macht, weil die quasi den Rechtskonservativen und den Nazis quasi so ein bisschen den Rang abläuft, weil die Symbole quasi wieder zurückohnen, ohne dabei fremdenfeindlich zu sein oder Nazis zu sein. Die spielen nur mit diesen ganzen rechten Symbolen, um halt irgendeinen Quatsch zu machen, aber ohne tiefere Bedeutung. Und so machen wir es auch mit der Telegram-Gruppe. Und so machen wir es mit der Telegram-Gruppe, weil wir als Gesellschaft neigen ja dazu, ganz neue Töne hier im Podcast, aber wir neigen ja dazu, uns Dinge wegnehmen zu lassen, die man nicht mehr benutzen kann. Ja, der reisst uns jemand aus der Hand, aber wir laufen nicht mehr hinterher. Wir laufen nicht mehr hinterher. Heya vielleicht noch. Heya. Heya. Sowas in der Richtung. Heya. Aber mehr auch nicht. Ja. Wo der Gegner schon merkt, die laufen nicht hinterher. Nee. Ich habe mir oft überlegt, weil ich habe meinen Rucksack immer neben mir liegen, in der S-Bahn. Und da habe ich mir auch überlegt, was passiert, wenn jemand mitnimmt und wegläuft. Ich würde wahrscheinlich einfach gar nichts machen. Das ist doch kein Schimmrucksack. Einfach nach Hause, wenn du normal die Fahrt voransetzt. Weil da kannst du nicht zur Polizei gehen, ja, mir hat jemand einen Rucksack geklaut. Ja, okay, wir halten auch Schauen nach Rucksäcken. So sagen die das dann. Ich glaube schon. So habe ich zumindest das Gefühl, die gucken dann so auf, während sie gerade so eine Leiche obduzieren und dann den Fingerabdrück nehmen und sagen, ah, wegen ihrem Rucksack, dann stehe ich hier kurz auf von der Leiche und komme kurz zu ihnen und sie beschreiben mir, wie ihr Rucksack aussah. Aha, ein schwarzer Eastpack, aha, alles klar. Es gibt nichts anderes als sarkastische Menschen, auf die du angewiesen bist. Das ist das Schlimmste, das ist das Schlimmste. Und das hasse ich dann wahrscheinlich, weil ich es an mir selber hasse. Aber wenn Leute zu dir kommen und was von dir brauchen, sei es eine Aussage, jetzt in meinem Job oder so was, oder in der Entscheidung, oder man aber selber auf solche Leute angewiesen ist und dann kriegt man so zurück so, ja, wir laufen jetzt dem Rucksack hinterher. Oh, haltet ein, der Wachtmeister läuft jetzt dem Dieb hinterher. Sarkasmus ist eine gemeine Trächtigkeit, weil du kannst nicht vernünftig darauf reagieren. Du kannst. Die einzige Chance ist natürlich, was wir machen, ist, okay, wunderbar, dankeschön, und einfach nichts. Oder halt richtig arschig werden. Was ist das jetzt für ein Ton? Und dann bist du das Arschloch, weil du plötzlich eine Szene machst, während der gegen der Sarkastische es sich viel leichter macht. Ja, entwaffnend, schwierig. Entwaffnend, ja, blosstellend. Sarkasmus ist eine Waffe, bloßstellend, furchtbar. Nicht mein Ding. Nicht mein Bier, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Nicht mein Bier. Bier ist auch nicht mein Bier. Bier ist nicht mein Bier. Bier ist nicht mein Wein. Können wir das als Sticker drucken? Nee, alle Druckereien sind pleite. Alle Druckereien sind in der Corona-Krise kaputt gegangen. Komischer Zufall, hat tatsächlich nichts mit dem Virus zu tun. Nee, they saw it coming. Das war seit Jahren schon. Die waren schon auf der Abschlussliste. Wir mussten alle, dass eines Tages alle Drucker gleichzeitig kaputt gehen. Jetzt tauchen ja überall diese Monolithen auf, auf der ganzen Welt, tauchen merkwürdige, wie aus dem Film 2001 geformte, ja, monolithenförmige Monolithen auf, die überingestellt werden. Und man denkt ja wirklich kurz, wenn es jetzt Aliens sind, denkt man, ach, dieses jetzt, sorry, ist nicht das nur noch. Wir sind gerade nicht in besser Form. Wir haben ja einen Schlafanzug an, irgendwie nicht rasiert, irgendwie Haare nicht gemacht. Müsst ihr wirklich jetzt kommen. Wir haben nicht aufgeräumt und die stehen mit voller Tatendrang in unserem Wohnzimmer und wollen uns abholen zum Spielen. Schnell, die intergalaktische Liga schickt uns, ihr müsst mitkommen, wir müssen den bösen Sorgon besiegen. Ah, du bist echt nett, geil, aber danke. Es ist wie so ein Sonntag, man wurde auf so einen faulen Sonntag
irgendwie erwischt. Ja, du ist
gerade ganz blöd.
Kommt so in 2000 Jahren vielleicht
nochmal vor. Und dann haben die eine Seite
behauptet, ja, ist Aliens,
die andere Seite behauptet, das sind mehr,
ist eine Kunstinstallation von irgendwem.
Ich, die auf der einen Seite,
ich glaube, das ist eine Kunstinstallation von Aliens.
Aber wie cool wäre das denn, wenn das sind Aliens?
Ein Prank. Aber es ist
letztlich eine Art Prank, aber so eine Art
Vielen Dank. Ich auf der einen Seite, ich glaube, das ist eine Kunstinstallation von Aliens. Aber wie cool wäre das denn?
Es sind Aliens, aber es ist letztlich eine Art Prank, aber so eine Art Installation von so einem Seidenschall tragenden, IT-förmigen Alien, der dann so Monolithen auf einem fremden Planeten mit so Fingerspitzen fallen lässt, und dann möchte man sich zurücklehnen und guckt, was passiert. Und wir laufen in einem Museum, läuft das einfach.
Vor allem so Aliens, wo so Aliens so gelangweilt mit ihren Kindern, die schon vorrennen und so laufen. Der einfach nur einen gesellschaftskritischen Diskurs damit anstoßen wollte, der will nicht die Weltherrschaft an sich reißen, der will der Gesellschaft einen Spiegel vorhalten mit diesen Monolithen. Das wäre das Coolste, das ist eine Art installation, aber von Aliens. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Aber meinst du, es geht noch weiter? Also werden da noch mehrere gefunden und am Ende ist das dann so ein Schriftzug oder was ist der langfristige? Oder ist es so Blindenschrift, dass wenn man einmal über die Erde so rüber geht mit dem Daumen, dass man dann an diesen Monolithen irgendwie so eine Art Blindenschrift hat? Genau. Also es wird die Hälfte der Menschheit ausgelöscht, aber ja. Ja, vielleicht sind Aliens wesentlich grösser und müssen über so Planeten kommunizieren. Vielleicht sind es so Wegweiser im Universum, wo die nächste Kolonie ist oder sowas. Die nächste Kolonie? Irgendwie sowas. Kein Buch auf Kolonisation. Nee? Nee, dieses Jahr nicht. Nee, komm. Werbung. Ey, Stefan, was würde ich dafür geben, wenn ich mich einfach mit Ernährung nicht mehr auseinandersetzen müsste? Wenn man einfach einen Löffel von einer magischen Substanz nehmen könnte und damit sozusagen alle Vitamine für den Tag hätte. Du, der Mensch braucht 75 essentielle Vitamine und Nährstoffe, um irgendwie halbwegs gut zu funktionieren. Glaubst du, ich habe die Nerven, mir zu gucken, wo ich meine 75 Vitamine und Mineralien zusammenkriege? Nein. Das wäre ja gut für deine Leistungsfähigkeit, für dein fucking Immunsystem, für deinen Energiehaushalt und für deine Darmgesundheit. Weißt du, glaube ich, was wir brauchen? Athletic Greens! Athletic Greens ist nämlich der Morgendrink für euch, den ihr einmal pro Tag zu euch nehmt. Und dann müsst ihr euch um diesen ganzen Quatsch keine Sorgen mehr machen, weil da ist alles drin, was ihr braucht. Euer Energielevel wird erhöht und ihr kommt einfach top motiviert und energetisch durch den Tag. Das sagen sogar Profisportler. So, und wenn die das sagen, call me in. Ja, so und das Beste ist, wie immer haben wir natürlich einen kleinen Schmankerl für euch. Geht einfach auf athleticgreens.com slash ufo und findet da ein Angebot und nicht nur irgendeins, denn wenn ihr Athletic Greens abonniert, bekommt ihr auch noch obendrauf ein Fläschchen, das ist ein Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und gerade in der kalten Jahreszeit, wo es keine Sonne gibt, braucht ihr Vitamin D3, nicht nur ihr, auch ich, aber selbst Florentin. Ja, ihr müsst nie wieder in die Sonne und ein Schmankerl selbst ist aber Athletic Greens auch, denn es schmeckt gut, hat weniger als ein Gramm Zucker und ist für jede Ernährungsform geeignet, also auch vegan, keto, paleo, was auch immer, ihr macht, lässt sich das gut integrieren. Werbung. Aber jetzt sind wir verwundbar, jetzt ist gerade schwierig. Meinst du deswegen? Kann auch sein, dass das alles von langer Hand geplant wurde, ist ja deine Theorie immer noch. Das habe ich dir eher so mal so erzählt am Wochenende. Aber es ist ein bisschen Arrivalval and lame, oder? Können wir uns schon darauf einigen. So, die kommen sind da und dann schicken wir der Sprachforscherin hin irgendwie und aber schicken Amy Adams hin. Würde man wahrscheinlich machen, oder? Hollywood schickt Amy Adams. Leider, das war eine Rolle. Ich habe, ne, ne, ne, mach das mal. Mach das mal an. Und dann schubst man die so hin. Es gibt schlechtere Vertreterinnen für die menschliche Geschlechter als Amy Adams. Oder Miss Universe immer noch. Eine von beiden zusammen. Die sitzen dann zusammen, Amy Adams und Miss Universe sitzen in so einer Rettungskapsel und müssen irgendwie viereinhalb Jahre zusammen zur Koloniestation fliegen, zum Mutterschiff. Schwer da ein Gespräch am Laufen zu halten, viereinhalb Jahre lang. Ist das ein Sketch? Kriegen wir Amy Adams für so einen Nachmittagsdreh? Einen halben Tag. Machen wir einen halben Tag. Ich glaube, wenn das Geld stimmt, kriegen wir die für einen Tag. Können wir zumindest mal die Agentur von Amy Adams anschreiben? Worst Bird Productions. Yes, we are planning a little sketch with Miss Adams. Just a half day, just a couple of hours. Couple of hours, here's 20 euros. Interested? Zinker smiley. Ein JPEG von dem 20-Euro-Schein. Here's a photo, so you know we actually have the money. Dann so mit roten Augen, wie du das in die Kamera... Mit roten Augen und so fehlenden Klamotten, zerrissenen Klamotten, wo man denkt, was hat er gemacht, um an diese so in die Euro zu kommen? Auch merkwürdig, in der Geschichte der Fotografie gab es so zehn Jahre, in denen die Augen alle rot waren, mittlerweile ja nicht mehr. Also die Digitalkameras machen das nicht mehr, aber es gab mal eine Zeit lang, hatten Leute halt einfach rote Augen auf die Fotos. Es war, weil das Licht so reinballert, reinbrennt, dass man die Blutgefässe sieht. Das kann doch nicht sein, das ist doch Bullshit, das ist halt irgendwie so eine Vampirlegende oder so. Und wer war der erste Entwickler, der das gesehen hat und wusste noch nicht, dass es ein Thing ist, dass ab jetzt die nächsten 20 Jahre Augen rot sind. Wie haben die ersten Fotos wieder darauf reagiert? Weil das ist ja grauenhaft, die Vorstellung, diese roten Augen zu sehen und so einem kleinen Kind, was einen so anschlagt, mit todroten Augen. Ihr von mir konntest die Fotos ja nicht sehen, das heißt, Tausende von Hochzeiten müssten fotografiert worden sein mit knallroten Augen, brettstechenden roten Augen. Aber das habe ich auch noch. Die meisten Fotos meiner Kindheit habe ich knallrote Augen. Man vergisst es, dass es eine Zeit lang einfach normal war. Mittlerweile nicht. Aber wenn du mit noch, wenn ich dir jetzt in die Fresse fotografiere mit Blitz, dann doch schon. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Optik ist eines der Themen, die ich nicht verstehe. Ja, das ist ein Thema, was du nicht verstehst. Konkav, konvex. Achtung, jetzt mache ich mal kurz ein Foto von dir mit einem knallenden Blitzlicht. Achtung, komm mal nah. Hä, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie man mit Blitz... War es an? Nein. Nein. Ach Gott. Das ist eine klassische Amateurfotografenfrage. Hört der Blitz an?
Okay, gut. Wir lassen es an der Stelle. Wir haben sie gebuft für 20 Jahre.
Ich habe zwei schöne Fotos von dir gemacht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie man das auslöst.
Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Ich habe in meinem Leben lang nur schlechte Fotos gemacht.
Ich musste aber mal Fotos von einem Abiball machen.
Das ist vielleicht das wichtigste Foto eines jungen Lebens zusammen mit dem Tanzpartner auf dem Abiball.
Da haben die beschlossen, die holen jemanden und die sind mit dem Fotoabkommen reinladen.
Eines dieser Dinge in meinem Leben, die ich mir rückwirkend schlicht nicht erklären kann. Also wenn irgendwann mal mein Biograf, Doktor Graf auf mich zukommt und sagt, Graf, Graf, Biograf.
Wie war das denn nochmal? Warum haben sie da auf dem Abiballos gemacht, kann ich nicht sagen, müsste ich lügen, müsste ich lügen, eine Piratenpistole müsste ich mir ausdenken.
Aber ganz kurz, du wirkst schon wie jemand, ehrlich gesagt, es ist fast ein Affront gegenüber der Gesellschaft, dass du keine Fotos machen kannst.
Weil ich finde, wenn man dich kennt, wie du damals aussahst und was du für Hobbys hattest, du warst so ein Fan von künstlerischen Tätigkeiten. Es ist fast gemein, dass du keine Fotos gemacht hast. Ich würde behaupten, Leute mit deinen Interessen haben auch gerne Fotos gemacht und so, sahen auch ähnlich aus. Ich hatte schon sehr früh ein Fotoapparat und ich war in Paris und habe einen ganzen Film verschossen.
Also als Urlaub mit meinem Vater und wir waren in Paris.
Und dann habe ich ganz viele Fotos gemacht, auch vom Eiffelturm und alles.
Und ich war so aufgeregt, dass ich schon auf der Hälfte des Eiffelturms so viele Foto gemacht habe, dass ich, als ich auf der Spitze war, keinen Film mehr übrig hatte, Klassiker. Und dann wurden die Filme alle entwickelt, alle überbelichtet, alle mit so einem riesigen sonnenroten Kreis drin. Der Mond? Und meine Mutter hat dann aus diesen Fotos eine Collage gemacht von allen Fotos, die überbelegt waren. Geil. Eigentlich ganz gut. Ein Foto war
wirklich nur weiß mit
rohem Rand. Also nichts war mehr
zu erkennen, als wir die waren wirklich
in so eine Kernfusion hineinfotografiert.
Einfach nur weiß.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, was das war,
wie ich das geschafft habe, aber es ist ein herrliches
Foto, aber völlig unbrauchbar.
Aber auch grossartig.
Wieso waren die Augen nicht rot?
Nee, das auf jeden Fall nicht so ein Foto, aber völlig unmauchbar, aber auch grossartig. Wieso waren die Augen nicht rot? Nee, das auf jeden Fall nicht in zwei Foto, wo man links unten noch so einen Schwan erahnen kann, aber der Rest des Bildes ist einfach knallrot-weiss. Aber man denkt so, was ist da passiert? Das letzte Foto vor dem Untergang der Welt, einfach schon sehr lustig. Supernova. Aber einfach die Blende falsch eingestellt, also keine Ahnung.
Willst du in Paris schöne Fotos machen? Blende auf drei.
Alter, alter Fotografen Limerick.
Lacht die Sonne, Blende acht.
Lacht die Sonne dir ins Gesicht, Blende acht. Ganz klassische.
Fotografiere lieber nicht, vielleicht ist das auch eine gute.
Nein, Sonne lacht, Blende acht, Sonne weg, Blende weg. Willst du drinnen fotografieren, Blende vier? Das sind die zwei, die ich so gelernt habe. Und dann gibt es noch die blaue Stunde. Liebe Sprichwörter, die man können muss, um den Sinn zu verstehen, wo der Reim nicht reicht, weil man es auch einfach umdrehen könnte. Wie zum Beispiel, bei rot bleibst du stehen, bei grün darfst du gehen. Ist kein gutes Brichwort. Auch auf der Rolltreppe, links gehen, rechts stehen. Das hilft nichts. Links stehen, rechts gehen, rechts gehen, links stehen. Das hilft mir nicht. Hilft mir überhaupt nichts. Reim auf links, machen wir es mit Binks, Jinx. Jar Jar Binks steht nämlich links. Der ist ja doof, deswegen steht der links. Jar Jar Binks steht links, weil der ist doof. Aber Jar Jar Binks läuft links, kannst du auch sagen. Hilft dir immer noch nichts. Nein, Jar Jar Binks, ja stimmt. Hilft immer noch nichts. Du müsstest Binks verbinden mit Laufen. Stehen links. Nee, links läuft man doch. Ja, aber Jojo Binks ja nicht. Okay. Das ist Canon. Zum Glück sind alle Dokammer stehen kaputt. Sonst würde sich unser Buch die besten Sprichwörter der letzten 20 Jahre eher mässig verkaufen. Auch so wie dieses, ich weiß nicht, ob es es überall gibt, dieses Oettinger-Bier, das so ganz billig ist. Und dann hieß es auch bei uns immer so, willst du dich billig besaufen, musst du Oettinger kaufen. Und ich habe damals schon angemerkt, das ist Quatsch. Das ist ein scheiß Sprichwort. Da kannst du alles einsetzen, das müsste sich auf Oettinger reimen, aber es geht nicht. Bist du ein Freund des Reims, wann hast du das letzte Mal aktiv gereimt? Wann habe ich das letzte Mal aktiv gereimt? Sie sehen hier, wie der Interviewpartner versucht, ein bisschen Zeit zu schinden, indem er die Frage noch mal langsam und nach jedem einzelnen Wort eine kurze Pause macht. Wann habe ich das letzte Mal aktiv gereimt? Nun ja. Und dann kommen so viele Folter, die man nie benutzt. Nun ja. Hinglängst bekannt ist ja, dass ich, nee, ich reime nicht,
reimen find ich doof, nie reimen?
Nee, ich finde reimen ist arrogant und albern.
Du stellst dich über andere, wenn du reimst.
Ja.
Und dann ist es auch bürgkonnotiert
durch so diese ganze Poetry-Slam-Richtung.
Dem Rappen, dem Freestyle
haben wir vor langer Zeit gewunken.
Hast du eine Absage gemacht?
Wir haben beide gesagt, das ist nicht für uns.
Stimmt. Wir haben eine Absage gemacht.
Eine Absage gemacht, wir haben beide gesagt, das ist nicht für uns.
Stimmt, wir haben ja noch viel Freestyle gemacht.
Ich finde Freestyle-Rappen immer noch eine coole Disziplin, aber ich kann es halt nicht.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, ob man das, du musst halt wie bei so vielen Instrumenten,
ich nehme jetzt die medische Stimme einfach mal als Instrument, dranbleiben,
das verklagt mich ruhig, du musst dranbleiben und du musst vor allem durch das Tal der Scham, dass du es einfach nicht auf die Reihe kriegst und es einfach sehr peinlich ist. Und da muss man durch. Da muss man durch. Wir hängen auf der Straße, in der ich wohne, hängen ganz auf der Niederlaterne hängen so diese Zettel zum Abreissen für Gitarrenunterricht. Warum macht man sowas eigentlich nicht nochmal? Warum hat man jetzt nur, weil wir erwachsen sind und unsere Eltern nicht mehr dazu zwingen, nicht jeden Tag faul auf der Couch zu sitzen, warum macht man mir sowas nicht mehr? Warum du zum Beispiel nicht? Du wärst das toll für einen Gitarrenunterricht. Ja genau, du meinst Unterricht geben? Nein, nehmen. Du sitzt jeden Tag faul rum, läufst nackt durch deine Wohnung und bist mittlerweile mehr in der Wanne als an Land.
Warum?
Ja, lass mich kurz da einhaken. Und zwar habe ich tatsächlich vor ein paar Monaten schon mit dem Gedanken gespielt, Klavierunterricht zu nehmen. Weil ich will Klavier lernen, aber ich habe Angst, dass ich mit der falschen Technik lerne und das dann mir so einpräge, dass es danach nicht mehr ändern kann. Deswegen glaube ich, dass es gerade am Anfang ...
Das ist das Schlimmste, wenn du dann da plötzlich später
irgendwie im
Berliner Palais sitzt, um
die Beethoven-Sonate zu spielen
mit der falschen Technik.
Dass der dritten Reihe ein Journalist schreibt,
oh, Florian, du spielst mit der ganz falschen Technik.
Das wäre grauenhaft. Wir sind uns doch einig,
angenommen, du kannst ein Jahr lang Unterricht
nehmen, das Beste ist es, das erste
Jahr Unterricht zu nehmen, oder? Und nicht fünf Jahre alleine und dann ein Jahr. Ja, aber du hast die Suggestivfragen gestellt. Oder? Ja, gut. So, dann lass mich doch einfach fortfahren. So, und jetzt gibt es zwei Musikschulen in meiner Nähe. Und dann habe ich mir geguckt und die eine ist eher so ein bisschen die poppigere, ja, irgendwie der eine oder andere trägt einen Hut. Die mit der coolen Website wahrscheinlich auch.
Die mit der coolen Website. Und dann habe ich mich so ein bisschen durch die Musiklehrer geklickt, weil man muss dann auch einen aussuchen, was immer so ein bisschen unangenehm ist, weil man keine Kriterien hat.
Außer das Foto.
Wie Tinder nur für den Gitarrenlehrer.
Und dann nimmt man halt die attraktive Russin, weil man sich denkt, ja, wonach soll ich es sonst bewerten, was soll ich denn sonst machen?
Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass mein ehemaliger Mitbewohner dort Musiklehrer ist. Und dem schulde ich noch Geld. Also ist die ganze Musikschule gestorben. Also es ist nicht so, dass ich ihm Geld schulde, es ist so, dass er monetäre Forderungen an mich gestellt habe, ein Jahr nachdem ich ausgezogen bin und ich mir dachte, ne. Und deswegen kann ich, ist ja auf meiner langen Liste von Menschen, denen ich einfach den Rest meines Lebens aus dem Weg gehen werde. Der Mensch unterrichtet aber nicht Klavier oder auch Klavier? Doch, auch Klavier. Und jetzt sagt die mir, gut, die ist raus. Dann also gehe ich zur anderen Schule. Die andere Schule ist halt so das absolute Gegenteil. Hardcore Klassik mit wirklich den heftigsten Namen aus China, Korea, Russland, heftigsten Leuten, einfach wo bei jedem Dozenten auch irgendwie die Liste an Konzerthäusern steht, wo die schon gespielt haben. Wo es auch billiger wäre, einfach dem Typen, dem illegalen Mitbewohner das Geld für die Stunden zu geben, plus nochmal 10.000 obendrauf, wäre wahrscheinlich billiger, als überhaupt bei der neuen Schule anzufangen. Ja, wo ich mir dachte, da kann ich nicht hin, weil ich würde mich einfach so fühlen, als würde ich deren Zeit verschwenden. Weil ich denke mir so, bevor die mich jetzt hier ... Nee, aber das ist doch da. ... da denke ich, ich könnte jetzt irgendwie in Mailand in der Philharmonie spielen. So stelle ich mir das vor. In der Skala.
In Mailand der Skala.
Das war die einzige auf der ganzen Welt, wo ich den Namen kenne.
Und jetzt, sorry, ja, arrogant und scheiße.
Aber dann haue ich es raus.
Du hättest alle Städte sagen können, ich hätte keine Ahnung.
Ja!
Und deswegen habe ich mich auch da dagegen entschieden.
Und deswegen, ja,
alles in allem, summa summarum wurde es dann weiterhin nichts. Und es gibt diese beiden in Köln und sonst keine. Es gibt nur diesen beiden und am Ende der Reise stand nichts, Leere, nichts ändert sich. Eine nicht die beste Geschichte, am Ende kommt Frodo ins Aundern zurück und es hat sich nichts verändert. Es hat sich nichts verändert. Er hat den Ring immer noch. Alle sagen, what the fuck? Bringst du dich wieder mit? Ja, vor allem, der Ring ist ja dahingehend eigentlich ganz spannend, weil du hast ja viele Handlungsstränge, die zwar ideell miteinander verbunden sind, aber nicht wirklich. Also so Aragorn versucht, Sauron abzulenken, während Frodo den Ring bringt. Aber die Geschichte wäre ganz anders ausgegangen, wenn Frodo einfach nach zwei Tagen Sumpf gesagt hätte, du scheiß drauf, oder? Du stinkst wie die Hölle, ey. Lass uns einfach wieder umdrehen, diese Ringnummer, das war ganz geil am Anfang, irgendwie hier Bruchtal und so. Also ich habe auch keinen Bock mehr, geh nach Hause und währenddessen noch Aragorn zieht in den Krieg, werden die einfach zu Hause sitzen und gar nichts machen. Ja, halt und irgendwie so Feste feiern. Ich finde es auch, dass die ganze Zeit während des Films im Auenland gelebt wurde wie bisher. Ja, stimmt. Und die haben, also was sagt uns denn das? Weil ich würde gerne einen Film machen, der während der ganzen Zeit, wo die schrecklichsten, furchtbarsten, actionreichsten und showigsten Kriege geführt wurden,
ein Film im Auenland, wo derweil das ganz normale Leben war, mit der Lehre, dass du auch nichts machen kannst, mit dem gleichen Ergebnis. Richtig, wenn du kein Held bist, bleib zu Hause. Und wenn wir feiern die. Weil im Buch natürlich Saruman noch versucht, das Auenland zu erobern und dort Kämpfe es gibt.
Und wenn Frodo zurückkehrt nach der ganzen Scheisse und den Ring vernichtet, kann er nicht einfach nach Hause zurück. Natürlich Saruman noch versucht, das Auenland zu erobern und dort Kämpfe es gibt.
Und wenn Frodo zurückkehrt nach der ganzen Scheiße und den Ring vernichtet, kann er nicht einfach nach Hause zurückkehren und sagen, lass es jetzt nochmal 40 Minuten Weichzeichner-Outros machen, damit die Geschichte zu Ende ist. Nee, er muss dann nochmal mit den Hobbits gegen Saruman kämpfen, bis er den besiegt hat. Also das ist dramaturgisch. Wurde Saruman nicht von den Bäumen geköpft? Nee, nee, nee. Tatsächlich im Buch wird er am Ende, glaube ich, von Grima auch getötet und so, ist ja auch egal. Aber da gibt es auf jeden Fall noch diesen ewig langen Epilog, nachdem der Ring schon vernichtet wurde, was ja dramaturgisch furchtbar ist. Ist Saruman von Grima getötet? Ja, im Film ja auch. Im Film wird er auch erstochen und ist eine Extended Edition Scene, aber ich glaube im Buch auch. Du darfst solche Fragen nicht stellen, wir kriegen hunderte Kommentare, das ist auch nicht so wichtig. Wir können das auch einfach selber nachgucken, wenn wir wissen wollen. Aber vielen Dank an alle Herr-der-Ringe-Fans, die jetzt natürlich eine gute Zeit haben, denn 4K, die Herr-der-Ringe-und-Torbit-Version kommen komplett auf 4K raus und ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich hoffe, das wird nicht auch wieder so ein George-Lucas-Desaster, weil Peter Jackson und George Lucas, glaube ich, sind sich nicht so unähnlich. Nee, ich glaube, ja auch. Sie sehen auch ähnlicher aus. Weil Peter Jackson in dem Interview auch meinte, er will, dass diese ganzen sechs Filme aus einem Guss wirken und dass sie alle gut zusammenpassen. Ja, vor allem jetzt ist ja die Frage, was gleicht er an? Also gleicht er den Hobbit an die ersten Filme an oder gleicht er die ersten Filme, die coolen, an diesen dreckigen Hobbit-Look an?
Ich hoffe ja nicht zweiteres auf jeden Fall, aber gut, solange er nicht die alten verbietet und man die noch konsumieren kann. Alles in Ordnung. Weihnachten ist bei mir Heiteringe Zeit. Ja, freu mich auch schon. Herrlich, schön das ganze Bonus machen, durch ballern. Njam, njam, njam.
Auch selbst im Film bei Disney Plus könnt ihr zu Mandalorian die ganzen, auch gibt es eine ganze Serie, Behind-the-Scenes-Serie.
Nochmal. Gutes, altes Bonusmaterial. Muss man echt sagen, Herr der Ringe, diese vier DVDs Bonusmaterial, das ist ja auch nicht selbstverständlich, dass es einfach zu so einer Trilogie auch so wahnsinnig viel Bonusmaterial gibt. Es gibt manche Filme, und das sind auch die, die ich am coolsten finde, die vor allem leben von den Geschichten, von den Behind-the-Scenes-Geschichten. Aber wann wird sowas entschieden, dass man sagt, wir wollen jetzt ... Ich glaube, je Kultiger, wobei bei denen haben die von Anfang an damit ... Aber es muss ja Leute geben, die sich darum kümmern, dass das gefilmt wird und so, weil du hast ja beim normalen Prozess, beim Film entsteht ja nicht Kameras dabei, dieses Film. Es muss ja aktiv jemand entscheiden, bei diesem Film wollen wir Bonusmaterial haben, lass mal irgendwie Harry den Praktik mitfragen. Ihr könnt jetzt draußen, liebe Filmteams, entscheiden, das Podcast-Ufo behind the scenes zu machen. Ja. Ihr könnt uns ab jetzt, oh Scheiss, begleitet uns ein Jahr. Ja, die Tür ist offen, hier ist nie abgeschlossen. Oh Scheiss, hier ist nie abgeschlossen. Jeder kann hier reinkommen. Jeder kann hier reinkommen. Jeder kann filmen. Wie sollen wir euch aufhalten? Sollen wir sagen, Kamera aus und dann so wild fuchteln, auf euch zulaufen? Nein. Sollen wir diese Kamera so auf die Linse drücken, das würden wir nicht machen. Das ist super nervig. Nee, vor allem, ich weiß selber, wie nervig das ist, Fingerabdrücke auf der Linse zu haben. Ich würde einfach sagen, ich würde die machen lassen, ehrlich gesagt. Sollen wir so einen Ordner aufmachen und uns vor das Gesicht halten, hier steht kein Ordner. Kein Ordner. Kein einziger Ordner. Nichts, was man sich vor das Gesicht halten könnte. Nichts, Hände vor den Ordner, nein, wir müssen das Mikrofon in der Hand halten. Genau, ihr könnt einfach hier reinkommen und das filmen. Ohne Scheiß, Angebot steht offen, wir begleiten das Podcast so ein Jahr, in dem nichts passiert. Also wir werden da wahrscheinlich einfach weitermachen. Es ist halt sehr unspektakulär, weil wir halt auf dem Stühlen sitzen und in dem Mikrofon reden. Da passiert etwas anderes, als wenn du irgendwie ein Schwert schmiedest und nur ein Location-Scoutest und so. Ist halt bei uns nicht so mega viel los.
Die einen sagen so, die anderen.
Ich glaube, es geht mehr um die Idee, überhaupt das mitzunehmen.
Könnt ihr zumindest euch andere Sachen anziehen, damit man das Gefühl hat, es vergeht Zeit.
Ihr habt jede Folge dieselbe Kleidung, immer dieselbe.
Wir sehen ja nur die Dokumentation, wo irgendwas krasses am Ende auch, also die geilsten Dokumentationen sind ja da, wo Leute wirklich über Jahrzehnte begleitet werden und am Ende crazy outcome, krasse twists and turns. Wie viele Dokus gibt es aber da draußen, die langweilig as fuck sind, wo halt die nicht veröffentlicht werden vielleicht oder auch einfach dann, wenn die veröffentlicht werden, nicht bekannt, zu Bekanntheit kommen, aber bestimmt sehr viele Dokus, wo einfach Leute zehn Jahre lang hinter dem Moment herlaufen und es bleiben halt die großen Twists and Turns aus. Oder der stirbt einfach. Ja, oder hat einfach keinen Erfolg mehr. Irgendein Musiker und dann jetzt begleiten wir ihn zehn Jahre und alle Album floppen, aber auch nicht so, dass man sagt, krasser Absturz, sondern halt einfach keinen Erfolg mehr und dann steht der halt rum irgendwie und fährt Skateboard ab und zu. Ja, sowas. Auch langweilig. Fände ich auch, ja, wäre auch langweilig. Scheiße. Wie viele Projekte hast du schon angefangen? Weil ich denke mir auch so, wie viele Leute haben diese Every Day Picture Challenge angefangen und haben nach Tag drei aufgehört. Ja, vor allem da gibt es ja mittlerweile so viele, die laufen, glaube ich, oder? Nach diesem einen, ich glaube, 100 Tage war der Erste oder sowas mit der Musik, den holst du ja auch nicht mehr ein, weil der hat ja schon Vorsprung, der macht das ja immer noch weiter. Du hast bis zu dem Zeitpunkt schon 90 Tage das gemacht, hat das auch die Idee und dann kommt der Erste und ballert es raus und dann kommt man selber und denkt, alles jetzt umsonst? Das wäre eine geile Doku. Achtung, Doku-Pitch, seconds. Eine Doku, fünf Mini-Dokus über die Zweitbesten in verschiedenen Sachen. So, wer wäre der zweite Mann auf dem Mond? Wer ist der zweitbeste Boxer? Wer ist als Zweiter ins Ziel gekommen? So eine Millisekunde. Aber die Zweite auf dem Mond ist immer noch eine Megadoku. Oder der nach Usain Bolt, wer ist als zweitens ins Ziel gelaufen, kennt niemand, der war wahrscheinlich so einen winzigen Bruchteil langsamer, irgendwie so ganz müh langsamer und kennt niemand. Den einfach mal interviewen, mit dem mal irgendwie so Frozen-Joghurt-Eis essen. Frozen-Joghurt-Eis essen, ja. Ein Eis mit Frozen-Joghurt-Geschmack essen lassen. Einfach mal gucken, was der so zu erzählen hat. Ist eigentlich Joghurt-Eis Frozen-Joghurt? Weil es gibt ja Eis mit Joghurt-Geschmack. Das ist die einzige Zeile aus Little Miss Sunshine, die ich nicht verstehe. Es gibt ja so Filme, die gucke ich immer wieder an. Du verstehst sonst alles? Ich verstehe, glaube ich, sonst alles, ja. Aber es gibt auch viele Filme, die ich sonst nicht verstehe. Twilight zum Beispiel gibt es auch einige Sachen, die ich nicht checke. Jedes Mal, wenn ich einen Film sehe, denke ich mir, what, was heißt das? Aber dann ist auch egal. Und bei Little Miss Sunshine geht es da so ein bisschen darum, die kleine Olive will Model werden oder halt so die Schönheitskönigin werden.
Und dann geht es darum, darf sie Eis essen oder nicht, weil von Eis wird man ja dick.
Und dann fragt sie selber aber die Schönheitskönigin, die Erwachsene, do you like Ice Cream?
Und sie sagt, yes I do, my favorite ice cream is Jerry Garcia, but technically it's a frozen yogurt.
Und ich auch frage so, warum genau, was ist der Unterschied zwischen frozen yogurt, weil dieses Jerry Garcia kennt man ja, warum sollte das Eis sein und nicht was anderes?
aber das ist ein so ein geiler Satz, den man auch mit reinschreibt, so in so ein Tüter-Eiscumpern, Cherry Garcia, but technically it's a frozen yogurt. Völlig unnötig, aber einfach ein cooler Satz. Cooler Satz. Gefällt mir richtig gut. Auch rhythmisch schön zu sprechen, but technically it's chosen yogurt. Rhythmisch ist so wichtig. Es gibt so einen geilen, sehr, sehr tollen Instagram-Channel, wo mir jetzt der Name nicht einfällt, den werde ich nachreichen, über einen Schlagzeuger, der The Rhythms of Comedy nachmacht und dann immer berühmte Stand-Ups nimmt und dann Schlagzeugbieter zu spielt. man merkt erst mal, wie viel Rhythm und Musik in richtig gut geschriebenen Punchlines ist. Auch so, was ich aber auch gedacht hätte, so John Mulaney ist einfach fantastisch geil rhythmisch und im Takt. Da kannst du wirklich zehn Minuten lang quasi in einem Takt spielen, wie er diese Geschichte erzählt, und muss dann nicht groß irgendwie das Tempo anpassen, der spricht einfach schon von sich aus fast sehr musikalisch.
Krass.
Und die Wörter sitzen, das ist was, da müssen wir noch hinkommen. Aber das würde ich auch gerne, aber da kann man auch eine App schreiben oder so, die einen dann selber begleitet, während man redet, oder?
Das so immer, wenn man redet, legt man so sein Handy daneben und immer so und immer wenn man redet, einfach so den Rhythmus. Das machen wir nächste Woche.
Das ist die nervigste Folge aller Zeiten. Bitte, was ist los? Haben wir gerade gleichzeitig.
Habe ich das gesagt? Nein, so bei. Aber das finde ich richtig cool. Das wäre für mich eines meiner
Ziele im Leben, dass jemand so ein Schlagzeugvideo macht. der zu ... So klingen Schlagzeuge, genau so. Böse Katze, böse, böse Katze. Ja, das war Beatbox-Zeit. Beatbox-Zeit. Beatbox war auch eine richtig schöne Zeit. Ich hatte einmal mit einem Beatboxer zu tun. Lustigster Nachmittag meines
Lebens. Einer der top
lustigsten Nachmittage meines Lebens.
Na, aber auch Nachmittage. Das ist also so.
Okay, weil
Nachmittage sind, würde ich sagen, eher nicht die lustigste
Tageszeit. Was ist die lustigste Tageszeit?
Top 5 der lustigsten
Tageszeiten auf Platz 5
definitiv morgens. Oh, der ist bei mir, der ist bei mir ganz oben, glaube ich. Ganz oben? Ja, ich sage dir auch gleich warum. Bei mir ist es auf Platz fünf der Nachmittag, keine lustige Zeit. Klar, 17 Uhr, da läuft King of Queens, da laufen die Simpsons, da läuft Schaf, man hat gerade irgendwie, man hat gerade vom Mittagessensloch erholt. Ja, gleich ist so eine barbernde Zwischenzeit. Also die Zeit an, in der Schulzeit hängt man nachmittags mit seinen Freunden rum. Ich habe 17 Uhr noch nie einen Gag gemacht. Noch nie? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Hassig. Okay. Auf Platz vier. Auf Platz vier ist bei mir Mitternacht. Wirklich so richtig ganz spät Auch vier war da oben. Late night ist bei mir nicht so gut dabei, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Da werde ich schläfrig, da werde ich eher melancholisch und philosophisch. Auf Platz vier ist bei mir so zwei Uhr nachts, also drei Uhr nachts, wo man so von einer Party nach Hause kommt und so. Da ist man auch noch nicht so, man denkt oft, man wäre lustig, alles nicht so toll, viele Gags schon gemacht, die Themen gehen einem aus und so, man guckt eher, wo geht der Abend jetzt noch hin oder lässt man es einfach oder ich will schon seit zwei Stunden nach Hause, also keine gute Zeit, nicht so lustig, Platz drei. Platz Nummer drei ist bei mir Mittag. Auf jeden Fall Mittag, Mittagstisch.
Klar, man will auch essen, aber sobald der erste Hunger gestillt ist, dann geht es auch ganz gut.
Das ist der Höhepunkt des Tages, was das angeht. Platz drei ist bei mir dann auch schon der Abend. Also so gut so 20 Uhr, da geht es dann wieder los. Also da macht man gute Gags, da ist man dabei, da bin ich on fire, da geht es dann los. Platz Nummer zwei Vormittag? Platz Nummer zwei ist bei mir frühmorgens. Ja. Es ist sehr lustig, nee, nee, Platz zwei ist bei mir eher Mitternacht. Man wird gerade müde und man rastet sich nochmal so auf. Und Müdigkeit ist generell, finde ich, super wichtig für Gags, weil dann kicken so Hormone rein. Wenn man zu wenig Schlaf hat, kommen die auch, das kennt man häufig, man ist sehr gut drauf, wenn man den Dach durchgemacht hat, am nächsten Morgen oder so mittags, wird man wahnsinnig lustig dann wieder. Deswegen ist für mich Mitternacht ganz gut dabei, wo man so auf dem Sofa eingepennt ist und nochmal aufwacht und dann plötzlich nochmal anfängt zu schreiben mit jemandem oder spricht und man ist dann wirklich lustig. Platz Nummer eins ist für mich ganz klar der Abendvorabend, also wirklich zu sagen, der Vorabend? Ja, 18, 19 Uhr, wirklich da kommen, sondern da wirklich die guten Shows. Ich tode ernst. Da kommen die guten Shows, man hat Bock auf Wetten, das, 20.15 Uhr, so dieses Wären, ich glaube, vor 20 Jahren festgehangen. glaube, 20 Uhr bis 20.15 Uhr, diese Zeit, wo man Bock hat auf die Abendshow. Das ist die Viertelstunde. Wo man Bock hat auf die Abendshow, man sitzt mit Freunden zusammen, irgendwie das Essen ist da, die Flipstüte wurde aufgerissen, aber die eigentliche Show beginnt noch nicht, man muss sich noch selber unterhalten, man ist aber so energetisiert und hat Gags und dann nimmt der eine den Pringles und macht so die Pringles-Ente und dann ist es nicht lustig und der sieht aus wie eine Ente. Ja, wir haben das Ding an den Mann verstanden. Das ist schon hilarious. Bei mir auf Platz eins ist dann tatsächlich der Morgen, der frühe Morgen. Nein, wirklich? Haben wir schon mal einen Morgen zusammen verbracht? Ja, wir haben so richtig die Augen gerieben und so, gegenseitig die Augen ausgerieben. Ja, wir haben in New York mal zusammen in einem Zimmer geschlafen, das weiß ich noch. Stimmt. Ich erinnere mich auch noch sehr gerne an diese Zeit zurück. Es war schön, weil ich habe dich immer gemocht, immer geliebt, als einer der lustigsten Menschen, die ich kenne. Und es war schön, mit dir, dich von morgens bis abends den ganzen Tag, also wirklich 24 Stunden zu begleiten, war für mich damals echt ein Highlight.
Und da haben wir uns gut kennengelernt, war auch schön,
wir sind uns noch nicht auf die Nerven gegangen, ich glaube, das kriegen wir gut hin.
Aber wir haben
sehr unterschiedliche Morning-Rituals,
beziehungsweise Night-Rituals,
ohne zu viel ins Detail zu gehen.
Aber ich bin, wenn ich abends
ins Bett gehe,
bin ich relativ schnell weg. Und bis spät in die Nacht habe ich noch so eine kleine Euglein auf dem Bildschirm gerichtet gesehen. Nebenan noch schön so eine Cornflakes-Box, wirklich immer gesnackt bis spät in die Nacht rein. Und er hat sich kaputt gelacht über irgendwelche Sachen, die er geguckt hat, gesehen hat und gefunden hat. Das fand ich immer lustig. Ich hingegen
ins Bett gelegt, weg.
Nee, da bin ich nicht. Bei mir geht es da erst los
eigentlich so. Wenn Einschlafen
der Gipfel ist, dann ist
ins Bett legen, das Schuhe anziehen.
Also wirklich, da geht
die Sache erst los. Erst mal gucken, wo geht es
überhaupt hin und dann erst mal hoch
und dann umkehren und so. Das ist ein langer Weg für mich,
einzuschlafen. Ich bin sehr
sehr empfindlicher Schläfer. hin und dann erstmal hoch und dann umkehren und so. Das ist ein langer Weg für mich, einzuschlafen. Ich bin sehr sehr
empfindlicher Schläfer.
Okay.
Jesus.
Tatsächlich sagen, wie sind wir da jetzt
eigentlich drauf gekommen? Irgendwas?
Ich jedenfalls wünsche euch
allen eine ausgeschlafene Woche.
Ja, schlaft mal richtig aus, nehmt euch
die Zeit, dreht mal schön die Heizung
auf und wickelt euch ein in die
Vielen Dank. Ich jedenfalls wünsche euch allen eine ausgeschlafene Woche. Ja, schlaft mal richtig aus, nehmt euch die Zeit, dreht mal schön die Heizung auf und wickelt euch ein in die Kissen. Mummelt euch ein. Die zweite Bettdecke ist einfach ein Gamechanger. Eines meiner Lieblingssätze, macht es euch mal gemütlich, macht es euch so richtig gemütlich, kuschelt euch ein. Entspannt mal auch den Kiefer gerade, entspannt mal das ganze Gesicht. Den Kiefer müsst ihr mal nicht unterschätzen. Das ist wirklich, die meiste
Anspannung ist auch oft im Gesicht.
Man merkt jetzt echt, entspannt euren Körper,
vergesst aber nicht das Gesicht. Auch mal häufig
am Tag einfach mal Gesicht entspannen.
Ja, sieht immer ein bisschen dusselig aus.
Ein bisschen dusselig aus.
Wir sehen ja alle ein bisschen dusselig aus.
Ja.
Entspannt mal das Gesicht.
Vergesst auf jeden Fall den Podcast-Ufo-Telegram-Gruppen-Adventskalender nicht.
Macht jeden Tag ein schönes Türchen auf.
Ich persönlich habe keinen Adventskalender.
Ich habe den Punkt verpasst.
Und tatsächlich ab dem 2. Dezember verkauft mein Supermarkt keine Adventskalender mehr.
Das ist dann auch assig.
Ja, einfach um zu sagen, so, ja, zu spät, mein Lieber.
Aber gut, den habe ich zumindest.
Wenn ihr gar keinen habt, habt ihr den Podcast-UFO-Telegram-Gruppen an den Eskelner.
Sehr gut. Macht's gut, eine schöne Woche euch. Ciao, ciao.
Wir haben ab.
It's a world's world production.